Has Ant-Man 3 been lost to the Quantum Realm
forever?
A source allegedly close to Marvel Studios
is reporting that a three-quel for the tiny
Avenger isn't going to happen, and that Ant-Man
and The Wasp may see their further adventures
relegated to the upcoming Disney+ streaming
service.
The rumor comes courtesy of rumor monger Mikey
Sutton, who points to two reasons in particular
for the decision to shrink Scott Lang and
Hope Van Dyne down from the big screen to
the small one.
First, Marvel Studios head honcho Kevin Feige
is said to be preoccupied with the task of
folding the X-Men and Fantastic Four, along
with the other formerly Fox-owned properties
recently acquired by Marvel's parent company
Disney, into the Marvel Cinematic Universe
— something he alluded to at San Diego Comic-Con
2019.
Second, Sutton claims that Feige is invested
in exploring different genres with the MCU's
Phase 4 and Phase 5 offerings — from spy
thrillers to psychological horror flicks and
everything in-between — so apparently, there
simply won't be any room left on the slate
for more conventional superhero adventures.
We submit, however, that this is nothing new
for the MCU, which has played in different
genres for years now …
"That's, uhh… naked.
Very naked."
"Huh.
That's… that's in my brain, now."
… but we digress.
Let's look at this rumor from a pure common
sense standpoint.
The "Feige is just too busy" angle has been
dragged out in one other recent situation:
as a pretty thin excuse on the part of Sony
Pictures CEO Tony Vinciquerra as to why his
studio and Disney couldn't re-up their agreement
to share custody of Spider-Man.
You'll notice that it's not actually Feige
complaining about how busy he is in either
circumstance; it's other parties putting those
words in his mouth for him, which seems a
little bit suspect.
As we alluded to before, it also doesn't make
a heck of a lot of sense to advance the notion
that because Marvel wants to do some different
things with some of its upcoming features
like the forthcoming Blade reboot legacy heroes
and/or their feature franchises must be left
behind.
If that were the case, we certainly wouldn't
be getting Thor: Love and Thunder, an unprecedented
fourth film for an original Avenger.
One could even make the argument that Ant-Man
and his supporting characters were more important
to the MCU's overarching narrative through
Phase 3 than virtually any others.
The Ant-Man films introduced the technology
that made it possible for the Avengers to
travel through time and acquire all of the
Infinity Stones before Thanos could; for that
matter, if Lang hadn't been freed from the
Quantum Realm by the timely inter vention
of a mouse - the universe would be toast yes,
that’s a mouse officially.
The Ant-Man flicks may be the lightest and
breeziest of the MCU's franchises, but they've
been charged with doing a surprising amount
of narrative heavy lifting and while they
haven't exactly blown up the box office, they
haven't flopped, either, together totaling
over $1.1 billion dollars worldwide.
All of these points aside, it's worth considering
that a couple of sources that we know to be
close to Marvel Studios namely, Paul Rudd
and co-star Michael Douglas have made public
remarks indicating that Ant-Man 3 isn't off
the table.
During a Television Critics' Association presser
back in February, Douglas indicated that while
nothing has been formalized, there had absolutely
been talks about Ant-Man 3, although he didn't
expect to hear whether it was actually going
down until, quote, "its third rewrite."
As for Rudd, he's simply gone on record stating
that he doesn't know when or if Ant-Man 3
will happen as recently as June, although
it's possible that he knows more than he's
letting on.
So, will there be an Ant-Man 3?
The simple fact is that we don't know, but
we have no compelling reason right now to
think there won't be.
The Ant-Man flicks have served a valuable
purpose as fun, light palate cleansers in
between huge, universe-shaking events, and
we think it's pretty likely that the MCU will
be in need of another one of those at some
point.
Also, Mr. Feige, if you're watching this:
please know that if fans never get the chance
to hear Lang's motor-mouthed buddy Luis recount
the events of Avengers: Endgame in his own
inimitable fashion, you can expect about four
million sternly worded emails.
"OK, sorry sorry…
I just — y'know, uhh…
I just get excited and stuff."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.